we have a list of 15 numbers here and
what i want to do is think about the
outliers and to help us with that let's
actually visualize this the the
distribution of actual numbers so let us
do that
so here on a number line i have all the
numbers from 1 to 19.
and let's see we have two ones
so i could say that's one one and then
two ones
we have one sixth so let's put that six
there
we have got a 13 or we have two 13s so
we're gonna go up here
113 and two 13s
let's see we have
three 14s so 14
and
14. we have a couple of 15s 15 15. so 15
15.
we have 116
so that's our 16 there
we have three 18's one two three so one
two
and then three
and then we have a 19 and then we have a
19.
so when you look when you look visually
at the distribution of numbers it looks
like the meat of the distribution so to
speak is in this area right over here
and so some people might say okay we
have three outliers the these two ones
and the six some people might say well
the six is kind of close enough maybe
only these two ones are outliers and
those would actually be both reasonable
things to say
now to get on the same page
statisticians will use a
rule sometimes we say well anything that
is more than one and a half times the
interquartile range from below q1 or
below or above q3 well those are going
to be outliers well what am i talking
about well let's actually let's figure
out the median q1 and q3 here then we
can figure out the interquartile range
and then we can figure out by that
definition what is going to be an
outlier and if that all made sense to
you so far i encourage you to pause this
video and try to work through it on your
own or i'll do it for you right now
all right so what's the median here
well the median is the middle number we
have 15 numbers so the middle number is
going to be whatever number has 7 on
either side so that's going to be the
eighth number one two three four five
six seven
is that right yep six
seven so that's the median and you have
one two three four five six seven
numbers on the right side too so that is
the median sometimes called q2
that is our median
now what is q1 well q1 is going to be
the middle of this first group this
first group has seven numbers in it and
so the middle is going to be the fourth
number it has three and three three to
the left three to the right so that is
q1
and then q3 is going to be the middle of
this upper group well that also has
seven numbers in it so the middle is
going to be right over there has three
on either side
so that is q
three
now what is the interquartile range
going to be inter quartile range is
going to be equal to
q3
minus q1 the difference between 18 and
13 between 18 and 13
well that is going to be 18 minus 13
which is equal to 5. now to figure out
outliers well outliers are going to be
anything that is below so outliers
outliers are going to be less than
our q1
minus 1.5
times our inter
quartile range and this once again this
isn't some rule of the universe this is
something that statisticians have kind
of said well if we want to have a better
definition for outliers let's just agree
that it's something that's more than one
and a half times the interquartile range
below q1 or
or an outlier could be greater than q3
plus one and a half times the
interquartile range inter
quartile range and once again this is
somewhat you know people just decided it
felt right one could argue should be 1.6
or one could argue it should be one or
two or whatever but this is what people
have tended to agree on
so let's think about what these numbers
are q1 we already know so this is going
to be 13
minus 1.5 times our interquartile range
our interquartile range here is 5. so
it's 1.5 times 5 which is 7.5
so this is 7.5
13 minus 7.5 is what 13 minus 7 is 6 and
then you subtract another 0.5 is 5.5 so
we have outliers
outliers
would be less than 5.5
or
q3 is 18
this is once again
7.5 18 plus 7.5 is 25.5
or outliers
outliers greater than
25.5
so based on this based on this we have a
kind of a numerical definition for
what's an outlier we're not just
subjectively saying oh this feels right
or that feels right and based on this we
only have two outliers that only these
two ones are less than 5.5 only these
two ones are less than 5.5 this is the
cutoff
right over here so this dot just
happened to make it and we don't have
any outliers on the high side
now another thing to think about is
drawing box and whiskers plots based on
q1 our median our range all the range of
numbers and you can do it either taking
in consideration your outliers or not
taking into consideration your outliers
so there's a couple of ways that we can
do it so let me actually clear
let me clear all of this we've figured
out all of this stuff
so
let me clear all of that out and let's
actually draw a box in whiskers plot
so
i'll put a another
another actually let me do two here
that's one
and then let me put another one down
there
and this is another
now if we were to just draw a classic
box box and whiskers plot here we would
say all right our median's at 14 and
actually i'll do it both ways our
median's at 14 median's at 14.
q1's at 13. q1's at 13 q1's at 13. q3 is
at 18. q3 is at 18. q3 is 18. so that's
the box part and let me draw that as an
actual
let me actually draw that as a box
so my best
attempt
there you go that's the box
and
this is also a box so far i'm doing the
exact same thing
now if we don't want to consider
outliers we would say well what's the
entire range here well we have things
that go from 1 all the way to 19. so one
way to do it is hey we could we start at
one
and so our entire range
we go let me draw a little bit better
than that
we're going all the way
all the way from
to
19. now in this one we're including
everything we're including even these
two outliers but if we don't want to
include those outliers we want to make
it clear that they're outliers well
let's not include them and what we can
do instead is say all right including
our non-outliers we would start at six
because six we're saying is in our data
set but it is not an outlier let me make
this look better
so we're gonna
we are going to
start at 6
and go all the way to 19.
and then to say that we have these
outliers we would put this we have
outliers over there so once again this
is a box and whiskers plot of the same
data set without outliers and this is
one where we make specific we make it
clear where the outliers actually are